was it common for President Biden to do  favors for Hunter Biden's international  business partners like writing College  recommendations for their kids I've seen  the report I have no confirmation or  comment on a report about whether or not  the president when he was a private  citizen wrote a college recommendation  letter for an individual but he's the  president now and you're his  spokesperson  correct and he was not the president at  the time of this report look at her body  language and her facial expression and I  read body language Dana for a living on  the side you can tell she's  uncomfortable and you can tell she knows  she's not telling the truth but she's  pushing the party line